AUDIENCE: What language
issues are particularly
poignant in today's
political climate
that they might
talk about today?
NOAM CHOMSKY: Well, one
issue that's critical
is the right of people
to have their lives,
community affairs conducted
in their own language.
So for example, if
some, say, dictator
were to take over
the United States
and produce an edict saying
the official language
of the country is
Swahili and that we all
have to talk Swahili from now
on and all official documents
are in Swahili.
And if you want to get
a driver's license,
you have to ask for it
in Swahili and so on.
I think we'd probably
object, but that's
the actual situation.
For example, in Haiti,
it's not Swahili.
It's French.
The language that
the people speak
is a different language, Creole.
So that's kind of a
problem that arises there.
Similar problems arise here.
We have Spanish-speaking
communities.
Do they have a right
to conduct their lives,
to have an elementary school
teaching in the language
that the children
know and speak?
Of course, they have
to be assimilated
into the general society.
But these are not
incompatible goals.
In fact, we know very well
that a multilingual environment
is actually stimulating.
It doesn't impede.
It improves performance
and understanding,
and being able to
live in your own mind
certainly has that effect, too.
So when I grew up--
not me personality, but the
communities that I was part of,
the native language was Yiddish.
And they spoke Yiddish,
and that was fine.
And when the kids went to
school, they picked up English.